what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports a game of dota 2
can and often does revolve around Roshan
the items he drops can be the key
between victory and defeat so it's no
surprise that a lot of the game's most
memorable plays happen in and around the
Rosh pit from agus steals to denies to
ganks to baits here are the top ten
Roshan plays holding the record for the
youngest player to ever win ti our
number 10 play see sumail put on a show
inside the Roshan pit in game 3 of the
2017 kiev major sumail blinks into the
pit and lands an insane five man coil to
completely wipe s genes and babies maybe
eg is coming they smoke up SG will go
inside the possession
she might be involved in this eg they
got the winning mermen
the final version back in this there
must be a massive size really for all
the EG fans known for their early Roshan
kills no tidehunter comes in at number 9
with a creative play that lured EG into
a death trap
during Dreamhack winter 2012 s grand
final admiralbulldog sacrifices his life
to roshan replicating a failed kill as
he baits eg towards him for a gank
tournament on
ladies lane there's a small blood patch
were Admiral bullet wrap and it is it is
actually trapped because they came to
check for it now this gun bigger I don't
know they're gonna bring it down oh boy
James now when the beam is the Swedes
they pull something out of the bag Oh
[Applause]
water stop what a strategy coming out
from it tell em be the profit bait he
doesn't lose any cold anything by
suiciding to Rocha
it's a pure bait he spent all his gold
on starting on him and no China just
come right out get two kills right up
the back no one has ever done that no
one has ever done that in the history of
dota 2 is a game that isn't short on
creative plays and number eight on our
list shows us just that in the g1
Champions League season 5 finals
Alliance stuns everyone with an
incredible level 1 Roshan steel so early
that even the casters were caught off
guard
TP made oh my goodness the Alliance they
shocked the world at Dreamhack with
their level 1 roach bait and now they're
gonna go for a five man roach TP this is
next-level dota
I am absolutely floored already no
matter how this turns out this is
creative as hell the radiant team is
going to as quick as possible but we
have blood loss we have aura from the
Beastmaster we have level and fury
swipes
we have eating novela slurp the bears be
summoned and they do have ton of damage
I think they have tested there is no way
that the radiant team to get in place we
will finish finish the Alliance are all
gonna be level two this could be a very
bad for DK if they run into that pit
it's too way to play they are scratching
their heads what the hell was that our
f-ck is going in that is not a good
decision when they're all level two you
will back off the alliance Lumi we
wanted a pocket strat boy do we ever
gala our number seven play C's s4 come
out of nowhere
- absolutely blindside ad finem as he
jumps into the pit to steal the ages and
turn the tide in oceans
on the s4 so I'll send a whole bunch
over they get the dust early God does
not actually describe coming in at
number six is mm wise cheeky play to
steal Roshan and deny the ages with only
familiars against see Dec young during
Game one of the summit for China lower
bracket qualifiers remilia's overhead
will see what they go for like a Roshan
last hit they go for it tonight
got the deny sick m-my play he stuns the
heroes with one Familia while denying it
with the other
okay m-my you've impressed me number
five goes to EJ's crit who pulls off an
incredible play as he jumps into the pit
against complexity to steal both Roshan
and the aegis topping it off with a kill
on to limp
the universe is trying to go for his
deal here to the orb gets vision crit
scotf Lincoln Burrows strike two he
looks he wants to try for to get ball
against the killers well it gets the
king of roached
Atticus the ages oh my god ro crit and
he's gonna get out as well after the
ages on what a steal on Vil I mean that
it gets big bro skill get limp get the
ages
and he does it all apply picture-perfect
look at the positioning blankets done
not only does he get to a just lift limp
ya feel shrapnel oh your hand to kill
what a boss number four on our list is a
god-like play that sees liquids gh
denies secrets puppy and Kazu of the
Roche steel during an elimination game
at ti7 roach they do scalp us out though
it is night time can secret make a play
here without the illuminate he'll this
is where Luna can be strongest but Mayor
Cole is hammering this roast down
quickly and he moves any one supports
out the BKB
puppies down secret are chapel's now
maracle chasing forward through your
phone that's a double diamond the third
spot on our list goes to the legendary
six million dollar echo slam at ti5 with
C Dec moved up tight in the pit PPD and
universe went in with an ancient
apparition
Earthshaker wombo combo that utterly
shredded CDE seized health bars
effectively winning the game then and
there they're all together PPT here
comes the ice planet
[Applause]
and now they will take Rosh Hashanah
get the egg into the immortal
even meat to buy time when they have
superior vision and CBC have no idea
it's coming universe was so convinced
that they're so sure they're in there
because of the vision showing them
moving down in that direction that it
just blindly blink echoes lambs there
are many kinds of plays in dota 2 but
the difference between average and
amazing lies right here at number two
during Game three of dream league season
eight versus Mineski Abed
single-handedly carries fnatic and pulls
off a game saving play that sees him
secure a three man kill and steal
everything from the Ness college and
they basically just gave away the Roche
Abed is he trying to make the skill
Chivas Garth giving vision he jumps
right in the aegis Superman right now
he's finally out of mana he could only
blink what he's won this team fight for
his team move over this guy is the real
superstar on this team
Abed game-saving playboy just steals
cheese steals refreshers chard snuffles
one short kill as well holy [ __ ] steam
rolling past the competition at number
one on our list is none other than aw
who's disgusting Aegis steel during the
semi-final match of ti7 between virtus
Pro and LGD foreveryoung off blue leaps
into the Rosh pit as he snatches away
the aegis in a play that could only be
described as Larson two racks out
against him and it looks like for the
Marvin rolling ball two
[Applause]
they fit the night
[Applause]
after the fight that lost at BPD healing
for them all the cut for this hard work
was a cheese an awful even prepared
Apple was confident they prepared two
slots in his inventory
he got one and then he got out if you
have not the cheese there that would
have been a site kill and they would
have had an ages to work with but he
gets exactly what he needs their
incredible play from him well guys
that's our list but if you thought we
missed out on a sick Roshan play that
should have been in this top ten keep it
to yourself okay
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]